Mario empezó el día con 5 flores de fuego.
Usó algunas y ahora solo le quedan 3.
Si "u" es el número de flores que ha usado,
podemos escribir la siguiente ecuación.
¿Cuántas flores de fuego usó Mario?
Empezó con 5, uso algunas, por lo cual
podemos restar ese número y le quedaron 3.
Hay varias maneras de hacer esto y una es
que lo hagas mentalmente,
piensas que si tenía 5 flores, le restó un
número y le quedaron 3,
puedes hacer mentalmente el calculo para deducir que tenía que haber usado 2 flores.
Otra manera de hacer esto es, bueno, tienes
varias opciones, puedes probar todas estas.
En este caso fue fácil el cálculo mental,
pero si hubiera sido más complicado,
podemos probar las 4 opciones que tenemos.
Si hubiera usado 0, tendría 5 menos 0 = 5.
Si hubiera usado 1, le quedarían
5 menos 1 igual a 4.
Si hubiera usado 3, le quedarían
5 menos 3 igual a 2.
Y al usar 2 le quedaron, 5 menos 2 igual a 3.
Y la tercera manera la vas a aprender a medida
que avancemos con nuestro conocimiento del
álgebra, aprenderás el cómo y el por qué
y te darás cuenta que esto lo puedes resolver
sistemáticamente por medio de un procedimiento
preciso, pero esto lo veremos en futuros videos.
Así es que él usó, 2 flores de fuego.